and if Trump takes over the Republican
Party I think we it's going to become a
right-wing nationalist party of the kind
or it's likely to become a right-wing
nationalist party of the kind you see in
Europe
hi I'm Nick Gillespie with Reason TV and
today we're talking with Randy Barnett
from Freedom Fest in Las Vegas Nevada
Randy is a professor of law at
Georgetown he's argued cases in front of
the Supreme Court and is the author most
recently of our Republican Constitution
Randy thanks for talking to us oh my
pleasure I wore my black shirt just in
honor of this interview Ruth Bader
Ginsburg recently said that Donald Trump
is quote a faker and you know you
shouldn't be led anywhere near the White
House or you know probably even you know
the Greater Washington DC metro area
she apologized for the remarks but
should she apologize is this a bad thing
to have judges making statements like
them well the first thing to say is that
it just shows that she's not wrong about
everything but then it probably I mean
it was certainly something that a
Supreme Court justice should not be
saying to the public and not and well
first of all it's evidenced by the fact
that she apologized and I don't think
she would have apologized if she hadn't
been taking a tremendous amount of grief
from her left as well as the right and
had no lit real leg to stand on
because she's got to be above that sort
of thing judges have to at least act
like they're above that sort of thing
it's certainly foreseeable that a case
involving the Trump campaign could come
before the court in the next few months
she can't possibly sit on that case now
and we only have nine justices they
should not take themselves out of
consideration and now I think she really
would need to could recuse herself a few
months ago you wrote a piece in USA
Today saying that if Donald Trump
continues to rise we need to form a new
party yeah that would be based on you
know actual constitutional principles do
you still feel that way now that he's
the Republican nominee you know what are
you looking to do on that front well a
third party run is now not feasible
because of ballot access requirements
but a combination of third party or
existing third parties and independent
candidates which is a different kind of
access is still feasible and I think
that such a thing as such an effort you
know it is being mounted and I support
it's being mounted to give voters a
better alternative than the one they
have and hopefully even
the beginning of a replacement of the
Republican Party what what is wrong with
the Libertarian Party candidate at this
point look until we know who all the
candidates are going to be and I think
there may be one more candidate that
will come out I don't want to say
anything bad about the Libertarian Party
candidate it he's clearly better than
Trump and Hillary I guess the easiest
thing to say is that I don't see a path
for him to win a single state and for
this a third for a third party or an
independent candidate to actually
accomplish something they need to win
enough states to throw the election into
the House of Representatives if you
could whip up an independent candidate
out of thin air who would it be is there
a particular person that you're you're
kind of pushing for is no person I'm
pushing for anybody who I would have
liked I think has taken that they've
already taken themselves out of the
running and so there's no sense
mentioning them there are certainly I'm
sure others that could be approached I
don't think this person needs to be
ideal to be a lot better it's like the
joke about the you're out running the
bear I don't have to outrun the bear I
only have to outrun you right they only
have to be better than Hillary and and
Trump and Gary Johnson they have to be
better than those three people
what would the independent candidates
stand for that would get your vote well
it may not be I think
the independent candidate might not get
my vote but I what I am for is a one of
as I say in my book Nick and you know
one of the two parties becoming a
constitutional Republican party and I
think the Republican Party is up until
now been the more likely one of it to
happen if Trump takes over the
Republican Party I think we it's going
to become a right-wing nationalist party
of the kind or it's likely to become a
right-wing nationalist party of the kind
you see in Europe and then it becomes
less likely for that to happen and and
just to clarify when you talk about a
constitutional Republican Party what
you're talking about is a a political
party that actually stands for limited
government yes and not fooling around
with certain types of basic rights that
we you know that are embedded in the
cost right let's just follow the
Constitution and what it also means is
descent is decentralizing most of the
important issues economic and social
to the 50 states and hopefully even down
to the municipal level and so that
people can choose the laws they want to
live under by which state they live
under rather than have to leave their
country in order to avoid whatever is
done on the national level what is the
most offensive aspect of Hillary Clinton
and Donald Trump individually in terms
of their overreach of this kind of
understanding of a Republican
Constitution I just don't think off the
spur off the top of my head I can name a
single thing for either one of them
they're just both awful in their each in
their own way when it comes to respect
for I mean Hillary Clinton citizens
united was involved Hillary the movie if
we're up to Hillary Clinton people who
criticize a presidential candidate
should be criminally prosecuted if they
do so within a window that's pretty bad
you know Donald Trump is bad on on
innumerable levels he's a wannabe
authoritarian but even if he wasn't he's
just an idiot yeah and sorry I'm sorry
to say you know let the cat out of the
bag guys not very smart and I don't even
think he's very wealthy either I think
my balance sheet is better than his we
have had for since Antonin Scalia died
we've had a four for Supreme Court ever
there's over not a four for Supreme
Court we only have eight justices I know
you're not in favor of giving Merrick
garland confirmation hearing or you
don't think he should be on the Supreme
Court
is it a problem how long can we go
without having nine justices to divide
you know to actually decide case how
long can we go or long will we go yeah
oh well these answer both no how long
can we go and go indefinitely the
original court the court has officially
had eight justices in the past prior to
it settling on nine as the magic number
and can I ask in FDR's court packing
scheme there was nothing specifically
constitutional then again saying we want
to increase the total number of the
number of justices is set by Congress it
is varied from five to nine and I don't
think it's ever had ten but it could and
that's what FDR proposed so there's
nothing magic about the number nine
except for the Beatles and
so but but so we could go and definitely
with ade except I don't think that's
going to happen I mean I do think that
if Hillary wins and I think that at this
point looks like she will win and I
think the Republicans will probably vote
on him right away
I think this particular position that
they took was based on the idea that
this was too important a decision to be
done prior to an election and the
election should have an effect on who
the justice should be and who the court
should be and when the election is held
that will be done and at that point the
Republicans will I think no longer stop
they won't stop it because they want to
fight him they'll just the reason for
the rationale for postponing it will
have been over will no longer apply and
then they will they will have hearings
all right well that's great we'll leave
it there Randy Barnett Georgetown Law
author of our Republican Constitution
thanks so much for talking we're always
going to be here for reason TV I'm
Nicholas
[Music]
you
[Music]